hello to my Korean readers and mave and
my publisher I'm sitting here in Maui
Hawaii taking a bit of a break from my
tour and I just received word that sales
of 12 rules for life in Korea are
approaching the hundred thousand mark so
I'm extremely gratified to hear that I'm
a great admirer of South Korean culture
I think that what you your people have
managed in the last 40 years is nothing
short of a miracle and filled with
admiration for your accomplishments I
would really hope that twelve rules for
life can help your people you know young
and old alike and encourage them to
develop a compelling vision for their
life and to take on this sort of
responsibility that you've been masters
at managing and to speak honestly and
forthrightly and to live nobly and to
bury your suffering properly and to help
make the world better and less
malevolent place and so thank you for
all your support so far and I hope at
some point to be able to come to your
country and perhaps talk to you thanks
very much dr. Jordan Peters